okay it's too brute now he's playing the
bird defense
so against the bird a really good move
in this position
is actually bishop g4 which is sort of
like the trumpowski now what is the idea
of bishop g4
as in many of these openings you want to
get the bishop outside of the pawn chain
before closing things up with e6
now we're going to develop the knight to
d7 and i'll explain why not
knight c6 after the game we take the
knight notice that he hasn't developed
anything what pawn break do we want to
prepare here for black
what is the key pawn break to prepare
and can we play it immediately
yeah so we want to play e5 now the sam
shanklin question as i always say
can we play e5 immediately now a lot of
a lot of you are thinking new
because of queen 65 but remember white's
made a lot of pond moves near his king
which changes the rules of engagement
for the center so if we play e5 and he
takes the pawn
we can deliver a very nasty check on h4
forces king to move
and then we can castle along we'll have
a huge lead in development his queen
will be caught on the crossfire
and uh we've only sacrificed the pawn so
it's very important
to always follow through on on this kind
of question he's gone bishop b5 pinning
our knight that's why we put it on d7
so that we could play c6 and blunt the
bishop's control also enhancing our
control of the center
now we're just going to continue
developing let's continue developing we
don't need to do anything about the
central tension we don't need to push
by keeping the center open we are
allowing ourselves to exploit our lead
in development
where do we want to put the f8 bishop
where do we want to put or do we want to
develop the bishop do we have an even
better move
we actually do so
people are right but we we have a better
move how can i find it
i want everybody to notice that he's
played h3 h3 has created a hole on g3
which is something you should notice
what can we put on that hole we can put
a knight there how can we put a knight
there we can centralize it this also
creates the threat of queen h4
which basically compels him to castle
but that castles right into a fork we
win an exchange
and will basically be winning right out
of the opening if he doesn't castle
we can decide between knight g3 and a
nasty check on h4 which i just mentioned
so what i want people to understand is
that when you're developing your pieces
you don't want to just put your head
down and develop automatically
you want to also detect the holes in
your opponent's position sometimes you
can move a piece more than once in the
opening
if it means that you're exploiting a
specific deficiency in your opponent's
position
okay let's see what he does well i
needed to get more ice cream
okay he's made a good move queen h5
now let's unpack this move for a second
he's just attacking our knight
if we go knight g3 he takes one knight
with check and wins the other one so
let's buttress
the d6 knight by playing bishop d6 now
sorry the e5 knight
and yet again we're threatening knight
g3 i don't see a good defense for him
if he castles then once again we go
knight g3 notice that
the e5 knight okay so he's gone here now
let's start let's let's try to
understand what our priorities are in
this position
our number one priority the move that's
going to devastate him like no other
is if we can manage to put a queen on h4
right i know a lot of people are looking
at discoveries
one way of doing that is to go queen to
f6 by threatening
the check on f2 we are going to force
this queen back
and then we're going to relocate our
queen to h4 what's another way
of trying to get our queen to h4 what's
another way of trying to dislodge his
queen
let's go queen f6 but i want people in
the meantime to think about
that question we could have gone g6
could have gone g6 attacking the queen
forcing it back
and then putting our queen on h4 that
would have been a little bit more
precise this move is perfectly good
enough
okay so he ignores the checkmate and the
game is over so that's why i don't
recommend these kinds of openings to
players even in the intermediate range
and we're 1500
so just to emphasize
just to emphasize g6
would have attacked his queen if he
sticks the queen on h6
actually that would have been a little
bit nasty well now again now we can play
queen f6 and he can't even stop us from
coming to f2
if he tries to go g4 what move does he
now allow
and i'm sure this is not the only win by
the way but but as an example
what move is now possible we can go
knight f3
and we can take his rook and we're
threatening checkmate that's unstoppable
because
he has neglected the development of his
king side okay
we'll analyze this game later in the
meantime let's continue
next game
okay let's go e4
and we have been playing several
different openings now h6
is not a good move and the reaction that
we've had
against such moves is to prepare the
control of the center with c3 which is
what we're going to do here
preparing the move d4 which we're going
to play anyway i don't care that he's
got knight f6 we're just going to
control the center thank you derp bite
for the tier 1.
okay so how do we solve the problem now
of the e4 pawn we have an intermediate
move that we can make
in order to solve the problem of the e4
pawn
by the way we could sacrifice it that
would be fine because we would open the
e file for us
and the common approach in this position
is to go e5 now
here i know a lot of people would rush
to say we should take on d4 but let's
think about this a little bit deeper
what is the drawback of the move queen
e7 the drawback of this move is that it
puts the king and the queen on the same
file
so we actually now want the e file to be
opened
and we we want him in effect to take on
e5 because that would set up a skewer
nor do we need to go queen e2 we don't
need to defend the spawn we simply need
to prepare for the opening of the e-file
by preparing to position a rook on e1
and we do that
by killing many birds with one stone we
castle
in order to save his skin he's going to
have to move his knight from f6
now and only now do we take on d4 notice
that his knight from g4 is now stranded
it has no squares so to add insult to
injury
we're going to just win his knight here
now he a good player would play h5
but that doesn't really solve any of the
problems inherent in his position
we can still take on g4 by the way in
that case okay well now he opens the f
file for us
now as i always say when we win material
the most common mistake that people make
is to forget the fundamentals they
forget to complete their development and
they run into problems
uh but let's not forget to complete our
development let's let's do that let's
put in the time
to complete our development let's go
knight to c3 and once he castles we can
also centralize our knight with knight
to d5 that's a good move and then
develop our bishop
pile up on a lot of these weaknesses
that he's created on his king side thank
you tj
rink for the prime appreciated my man
appreciate it my man
okay so let's centralize our night okay
hopefully this is making sense to people
another thing that we could consider
doing here is to go knight f6 track and
try to take his bishop out of the
equation so that his king gets even
weaker
but there's no need for such
extravagances we can just pile up on his
h6 pawn this is sort of a classic method
of
attacking in such positions okay
but now the temptation to play knight f6
has been raised because his queen is no
longer guarding that square
again what i want to emphasize to people
is simplicity like the power of playing
in a very simple fashion so we're
actually not going to go knight f6 even
though that's the move i would have
played in a game
we're just going to continue with our
sort of conventional plan here
and only now well okay so still we're
not going to plan out f6 what would be
the simple way to accumulate pressure on
his king
on his king's side let's say there's one
more piece that we haven't deployed yet
let's deploy it
let's deploy let's deploy the last
remaining piece
which is the rook and i know that this
might strike people as a very formulaic
way of playing like okay where is the
checkmate where's the sacrifices
but trust me in order to master dania
style you have to master
the fundamentals of attacking which
which is to say
the art of bringing all the pieces in
very patiently and doing the fundamental
things very well
okay now it's time it's the wax on wax
soft method now it's time for some
tactics
this king on h7 is subject
to a discovered attack sorry to a check
by the knight on g5 but this check
in and of itself is is a night blunder
he just takes her knight but it could be
used as a discovery down the f file
by combining these two observations we
see the move bishop takes f7
distracting his rook onto a square where
it can be picked off with the discovery
now some of you are looking at this and
saying okay i get it
why are you giving up two pieces for a
rook isn't that good for black well no
because look at his king
his king is now encircled by our pieces
we're still up in exchange
on the next move we're going to take on
g5 and basically checkmate him
so how did i see the move bishop takes
f7 what made me find it it's the fact
that i saw that we have a check on g5
and one of the properties of this check
is that it opens up the f file so if he
has something on the f file that's
vulnerable
we can give this check in order to pick
it off right you have to do this kind of
observation
all the time you have to constantly
notice these sorts of things otherwise
you're not going to find
these types of tactics and and
you know there were many formative books
that that caused me to raise my
awareness of this
one little known book that i can
recommend to people is called chess
middle game combinations by
peter romanovsky originally in russian
romanovsky was
a early 20th century chess master and he
wrote a fantastic book on on seeing
tactics
so uh hopefully this game made sense to
everybody
let's play one more and then we're going
to analyze
let's play one more blitz game and then
we're going to analyze all three we're
going to play apache
same rating as us right now okay
so he's playing the sicilian we're going
to play the open situation which i've
been doing
okay so he plays e5 which is called the
kalashnikov variation
it's a pretty common variation of the
sicilian and
black strikes in the center immediately
but the drawbacks of this move are
pretty evident right
the drawbacks of this move are that it
weakens these two squares principally
square on d6 and square on d5 and we
have to maneuver our pieces in order to
exploit those and so knight b5 is the
main line here
and then we're going to bring up the
other knight in order to access d5
the other weak square that has been
created this is all theory by the way
this is all theory and we have
transposed into what's called the
ceveshnikov now
what we don't want is for our knight to
be easily dislodged from d5
we want to keep this knight on t5 but
what's preventing us from doing that is
his knight on f6
so we're going to develop our bishop to
eliminate it thank you socrates
now and i'm sort of trying to explain
why the theory is a theory
this knight on a3 everybody should
notice is very
misplaced right it has no prospects so
what we're going to
go about doing is giving this knight
some prospect particularly we want to
maneuver it to somewhere civilized
so we're gonna go c3 in order to deploy
this knight through c2 it's not ideal
but at least our knight is now doing
something
okay so this is the main line of the
swashnikov
so far he's been playing all the
theoretical moves kudos to him
now the other thing that people should
notice here
c4 is also a move by the way but it
would weaken the d4 square but c4 is a
theoretical move as well
the other thing that i want people to
notice here is that there's there's a
pawn on b5 which is sort of sticking out
like a sore thumb
how do we go about undermining or
perhaps trying to exploit the weakness
of this pawn it's a very typical idea
you'll see this also in the rye lopez
you'll see this in a lot of openings
yeah we go a4
to to try to break up this pawn
and also deploy the rook via the a-file
it's always nice when you don't have to
move a piece and it already participates
in the game
i have read parts of reassessor chess
although i wouldn't say that i've read
the whole thing
okay so let's see what he what he comes
up with here
all right so i think the theory maybe he
takes the knight here i don't know then
we'll take with a queen
and the queen ably performs the task
previously fulfilled by the knight
uh maybe i should have supported my
knight by playing knight c to e3 that's
another way of doing it
he takes and so will we and by taking
he's also given our bishop a very nice
square
where where can our bishop now go to
in order to support the knight
well and c9 to answer your question we
were waiting for the square to open up
for the bishop
development is not something that should
be rushed all the time it's it's a
priority but you should make sure that
you're
giving your pieces good squares before
before you're developing
now he's given up a pawn on a6 i think
we're just going to snag that one if you
don't mind
that's a free pawn in my book now there
is a little bit
of pressure down the a file we should be
careful about that particularly because
this rook is unprotected but
what i'm seeing is that i can later move
my bishop back to b5
that bishop is going to simultaneously
defend the rook on a4 so
while this is something to keep an eye
on it's not something to be overly
concerned about
okay so he takes we take as we know i
don't really see where he's going with
this
i don't really see he could have taken
with a rook but again i don't see a
point to shy away from this tension i
don't see even how he
attacks this bishop another time and
even if he does
we have many ways to defend it we can
defend it with our queen which is what
we're going to do we're going to drop
the queen back
in order to lend some additional support
to this bishop this guy is good though
he's
he's not going down without a fight but
you can see that the cracks are
beginning to show
okay and now is a great time to show why
we've deployed this knight to c2
there's a there's a move here that i
call a glue move there's a move that
glues together
all of the disparate parts of white's
position it stops the queen from
attacking b2 it lends further support at
the bishop
and it just glues everything together
very nicely that's the move knight to b4
as some of you are pointing out
this is a glue move this guy is good as
i said this guy is very good he's
underrated but white is definitely
better here okay b2 was also hanging out
that's important
f2 is not hanging because it's simply
protected by the king
let's see what he comes up with here
okay now we have
we have time for a simple prophylaxis
what is the point of this move where is
the knight going
how do we stop it from getting there two
questions
let's answer them both the knight's
going to f4 obviously
how do we prevent it by going
g3 right this is simple prophylaxis a
good observation is that d5 square is
also free
we don't want to rush putting our knight
there remember that the knight on b4 is
fulfilling the crucial role of defending
b2
thanks okay he's gone back excellent now
we can
complete our development by castling
okay so he's gone f5 now
you know a lot of people would be
worried about this move oh my god he's
opening the file but
let's take a second and understand the
drawbacks inherent in this move
what is the drawback of pushing the
f-pawn when you're castled one of them
is that you by definition weaken this
diagonal
so what we need to notice here is that
this check on c4 might be very strong in
a couple of moves
let's take on f5 let's if he takes back
we're gonna make a discover check and
his knight is gonna be lost i think he's
noticed that
so he's gonna have to give away another
pawn he can't recapture on f5
well he did but this knight is defended
by the rook
this rook also defends the other rook
which means it's overloaded
by giving the check we are exposing the
tension of the rooks
boom and boom and we're up a night and
we're up a pawn and we're winning
so the the most important moment in the
game was g3 this made him frustrated
it made him frustrated he got impatient
trying to create counter play
and he fell apart very very quickly now
he realizes it but it's too late
okay let's capture the knight and now by
the way
if you notice the bishop and the queen
they can combine in a battery
threaten checkmate and the bishop on f6
is going to be lost as well because to
defend against it he's got to give it up
okay the art of attacking the king i'm
not sure what book that's referring to
okay he runs we're going to take it
how do we continue harassing the king
after it moves to f7 which piece can we
deploy
to attack the king and how can we deploy
it
also notice by the way the move knight
t5 could potentially be a fork yeah
bishop c4 or bishop g6 are both good
now our goal here is to get the king
onto e7 because that is a forkable
square
so we need to kind of assess all of the
checks that we can make here including
retreating moves in such positions
people often misretreating moves and
they are the art they are the glue that
makes the attack run
the bishop on g6 is cutting the king off
from f7
as many of you are seeing good job guys
queen h3 forces the king onto e7 that is
literally the only move
and that king walks right into the fork
with the knight
we won this queen and we won the game so
the game is over
good very very good okay
and um you can see that we didn't do
anything extraordinary we played the
theoretical moves
and he collapses quite quickly so very
good
kelly from sales gifting five subs to
the community stoke in the fire
really really appreciate that um
legendary matrix
gianlucille kendall jc one temper all
getting subs
thank you so much and 34.77
boys and girls incredible
um really big fan of the glue metaphors
i like blue moves
okay so let's um which i think we
actually explained the games quite well
i don't think there needs to be any
over explaining to do but let's just
look at this game for a second
now okay
so boom this is all very simple now the
move c4 here some people were suggesting
is also very fashionable theoretically
uh but the issue is that it weakens the
d4 square so
that move does have a drawback its
strength is that you you
get your development out faster because
c4 occurs with tempo
you you attack the pawn on b5
simultaneously
i made a lot of night moves in the early
going i did but
he also made a lot of concessions which
allowed me to violate some of these
rules in particular he weakened
the square on d5 and when you get to
that level of 1500 you have to
understand that
these rules that you that you follow in
a very
linear fashion when you're a beginner
you start to bend them very slowly and
one of the rules you start to bend
uh is that you you know you um
you you can allow yourself to move the
same piece more than once because
opening theory starts playing a pretty
big role and modern opening theory
involves
a lot of violation of of rules if that
makes sense so
it's sort of a negotiation between
continuing to follow principles but
understanding when to violate them at
the same time
yeah let's check the oh so somebody said
we had high accuracy in this game
let's see i'm curious now
people were supplying the move so i
didn't do much yeah
99 let's go so simple rules
simple logic produces good chess
okay um
well every people were supplying the
most to me i wasn't really doing much
okay must be cheating that's right
let's continue though one more
pow mondatto 1577 and let's once again
play the situation
in the accelerated dragon which is the
opening that i recommend to people in
the 1500 range
this is a move we've seen often knight
takes c6 it's a mistake
because he gives us greater mobility in
the center greater ease of organizing d5
now we have some problems to solve the
rook is hanging which means we should
develop our knight and defend the rook
at the same time
yeah this is a theoretical line where
they can go e6 and it seems like
a lot is going on oh my god have we
blundered he's discovering the attack on
the rook in reality
this is one of those lines where if you
look a little bit deeper
you find the black is doing completely
fine because remember he doesn't have
anything out yet
so we're just gonna go f6 to block the
queen's attack on the rook i know i said
never play f6 but
there's a reason why this is an
exception and i'll explain that in
greater depth after the game
now one of the reasons why f6 is okay
here
is because the move f6 prepares what
central advance
what central advance is now possible
with tempo because we played f6 yeah the
movie five is now possible
thank you t brown 03 for the prime
yeah this is now possible and um
not only is this possible but this is
really good because we open up the
bishop as well
and where should we put this bishop we
can put it on d6 for example
we can also deploy our queen to b6 so
it's actually staring at some pawns
and potentially it's also permitting us
to play bishop e6 to lend some support
on this weakened diagonal
that's exactly what we're going to do
here in order to support this knight on
d5 hopefully this makes sense
okay now what should we take with and
both both recaptures are fine but but
according
to sort of our way of thinking
let's take with a pawn um
here we go with this again let's take
with a pawn because now we have
we have a really nice pawn center we're
going to castle to attack up
to defend f6 we're going to castle to
defend f6
okay bishop h6 so it seems like he's
tossing us around but he's actually not
uh he's just sort of he's making these
moves that look active but the reality
is we have control over the center
um he has these two pieces that don't
really do anything they're just sort of
sitting there
because our king's side is perfectly
well defended
where should we put our rook let's well
we don't need to play g5 we don't need
to kick his queen away from a square
where it's already not doing much
okay c4 okay now
we can take on c4 and make a weakness
or we can push d4 and we can expand our
central control which is what we're
going to do
and then one idea is to play f5 and well
g5 does strap the bishop but you've got
to be careful about weakening your own
king
okay now well there's a couple of ways
to approach this position
we want to play e4 we can't do that yet
so the simplest way to approach this
position would be
the simplest way to approach this
position be just to play f5 and prepare
e4
it's a little bit risky to introduce
some more weaknesses in our king side
but
there's just no way that he can exploit
them there's just no way that he can
exploit them
and um let's see what he ends up doing
but e4 d3 is just a massive threat
yeah he doesn't actually stop us from
playing e4 that's partially why we
positioned our queen on b6 that it
guards d4
and allows us to prepare d3
okay how he could exploit it yeah maybe
after the game
yeah we could have also played a5 to
sort of slow down the progression of his
pawns but there's no need for that yet
all right let's continue our pawn storm
no need to no need to stop
okay
so there are some tactics here takes
takes rook to e3
yeah so this is where this is where the
tactics come in
and the concrete calculation comes in so
we have two ways to capture we can
capture this bishop or we could capture
this bishop
the move that we should start with is
the move that may yield the most
benefits
if it works which is d takes e2
attacking the
rook has to go to d2 and in that
position those of you who want to
practice their visualization
what is the move after d takes e2 rookie
2 to harass that rook
and force material losses the move is
going to be e3
right because if he takes e3 we're going
to fork his king and his rook
this is where concreteness transcends
general appearances it looks like why
are we partying okay so he gives up the
bishop straight away
without a fight now we're up a piece and
now the win is
very straightforward we can let's put
our rook on a good square on an open
file
and now we can go go about playing down
the d file we can triple on the d
file and then focus on putting a rook on
d1 which is going to be the simplest
strategy
and um we're in great shape here
we're in great shape here and uh the
royal triple
but we would move our queen away from d6
in order to
set up the possibility of putting a rook
on d1
okay yeah load up alakine's gun
that's also possible
okay
here comes ellicott gun the queen isn't
doing anything
and um this is not made because he takes
and he goes rookie one so we should be
careful about that but we can we can
trade queens
how can we force the trade of queens
how can we force the trade of queens it
was not made before either
because he could have gone rookie one no
no it was not made
guys i did not miss mate because queen
d1 he has rookie one immediately
it's not made guys i saw that trust me
i'm not i'm not gonna miss a back rank
mate like this
so this forces the trade of queens
because if his queen
leaves the rook then we simply take his
rook and why is it good to trade queens
here because we have control over a file
uh and and okay now we're gonna play e3
just uh cement this past pawn we can
play f4 later
yeah so now we're gonna go rook d1 he's
gotta go rookie one
otherwise he's checkmated now it's a
good idea to do this because we trade
rooks
and we've got to be a little bit careful
our top priority is to
is to support the pawn on e3 so we're
going to go g5
okay we're going to carve out some real
estate here
we're going gonna go after this pawn and
our secondary idea is to position the
rook behind the pass pawn
in order to preserve it
okay let's move our bishop to f7 so that
we can meet king f3 with bishop h5 check
and dislodge the king from the pawn
also that bishop is going to guard the
e2 square so we're going to be able to
push our pawn to e2
i mean i'm not really explaining my
moves here on a granular level because
there's many ways of winning such a
position and
i'm just making pretty straightforward
moves
okay he's good though he's he's playing
resiliently
and in order to win this we need to
involve our king
so let's go king g7 also if he goes h4
it's checkmate
which is kind of funny he actually might
go h4
thank you john cena appreciate it glad
you're enjoying it
this all most of this will be on youtube
i don't put every single speedrun game
on youtube because that would be
cumbersome now we go h6 how should we
follow up after king h4 what should we
do
what should we do we should take take on
f4 step back to e4 and then we have
connected passers
then we have connected passers
okay we're not going to let his rook
take we're going to go bishop h5
and um yeah now it's very simple
because the bishop has been charged with
control of the pawn we can just move the
rook to d1
and uh we can force the trade of rooks
and then finally we can grind
okay so he takes that's fine
rook b1 takes and now we can just push
our pawn forward that's fine
i wonder who's going to win the
ponderers we actually have to be careful
f2 c7 we can't stop this pawn of course
that would still be completely winning
but we've got to be careful about that
okay we can give up this pawn and win
the other one it really doesn't matter
just go around he should resign
he should resign
yeah and he does okay great
that was an interesting game um
let me see so i think one of the keys to
the kingdom here was this move f6
uh you know you always say never play f6
but f6
does create certain weaknesses on our
king side but on the other hand
uh it it supports the building of a
center and this is one of those other
things i mentioned about
weighing the pros and cons of a
particular move
and deciding that because he doesn't
have enough stuff developed we can get
away with something like this
okay so it's it's always important to
weigh the pros and cons
of everything that you're doing
particularly the move f6
so here we just can complete our
development the queen b6 deploys our
queen onto a really nice square
what also makes this move good is the
fact that he cannot put his bishop on e3
because that square is protected and um
yeah we're in fantastic shape here now
we put the other bishop on e6 we don't
want to give away
the knight on d5 that's our strongest
piece
and um basically that that that was what
won us the game i think
yeah and then then we just prepared the
pawn storm and then we found the tactics
if you've gone rook two in this position
we would have gone e3 and uh he's in
huge trouble because his rook
well i guess he has rook t4 maybe but
that then maybe we play up four actually
and then again we separate his queen
from his rook
so this is just very very good good
position for us we could have also taken
the other bishop
and and and kept our pawn chain but this
is sort of
place to the concept of transformation
of the advantage
uh so anyways guys
[Music]